thank you
well this gives a band and the chorus
another round of applause that was
absolutely
[Applause]
good morning President Biden Dr Biden
vice president Harris Mr imhoff
distinguished guest I am absolutely
honored to be here with you this morning
and thank you general milley for your
leadership
to our gold star families and to all who
remember a fallen American hero today
I know that each Memorial Day brings new
waves of both pride and pain
and on behalf of the Department of
Defense
please accept our country's deepest
gratitude
for all that you have given
in our deepest sympathies for all that
you have lost
we pledge again today to ensure that you
and your families have the support that
you need and deserve
you will always be a part of our
military family
and we hold in our hearts all those who
fell to defend the country that they
loved
each of them has a story
and one of the stories of the graves
here at Arlington
belongs to chaplain Charles Waters
he was a Catholic priest
who signed up to serve during the
Vietnam war
and to support his teammates
in body and soul
and after a year-long deployment he
volunteered to extend his tour
for another six months
in one November Day in 1967 his
Battalion hit Fierce fighting
chaplain Waters ran unarmed into the
battle
exposed to mortar fire bullets in
automatic weapons
he helped get wounded soldiers to safety
and he gave last rights to the Fallen
at one point he saw a U.S paratrooper in
shock
in the line and in the line of enemy
fire
chaplain Waters hoisted the paratrooper
on his shoulders
and carried him to safety
tragically later that day chaplain
Waters was killed
and for his extraordinary heroism
this paratrooper
Patriot and priest
who volunteered twice wants to serve and
wants to extend his tour
was posthumously awarded the Medal of
Honor
this year
our country celebrates the 50th
anniversary of our all-volunteer Force
in the life of Charles Walters
Charles Waters offered a preview of the
Vigor in The Valor of the of the
American warriors who have chosen to
step up and serve from 1973 until this
day
our all-volunteer Force has Blended
military power
with moral power
and combine the force of American Arms
with the strength of people who freely
choose to stand guard over our democracy
in 1970 the gates commission recommended
eliminating conscription
and its formal report predicted that an
all-volunteer Force
will strengthen our freedoms and our
Armed Forces
and it did
every time a qualified American stands
up and raises their hand
and serves With Honor
from any corner of the country from any
background color or Creed
this exceptional Nation becomes even
safer and stronger
every Fallen Hero has a story
it is our duty to remember those we have
lost
it is our honor to stand with their
families
and it is our sacred obligation to
remember all that you have given
so let us strive to honor the memory of
our fallen
by writing the next chapters in
Americans America's story of service
let us stand with all who pledge
their lives to defend human freedom
and let us come together as one nation
to strengthen our democracy
ladies and gentlemen our
commander-in-chief has long been a
champion
of our men and women in uniform
in other military families who serve
right alongside them
and on this day of sorrow and service
it is my absolute honor to introduce the
president of the United States
[Applause]
thank you
thank you thank you thank you please
[Applause]
155 years ago
retired Union general
James Garfield spoke here at Arlington
marking our nation's first Memorial Day
standing amid rows and rows of marble
stones
many of his own Fallen Soldiers among
them he asked
what brought these men here
what high motive
LED them
to welcome death
and he answered his own question
he said our nation's life
my fellow Americans
Jill vice president Harris second
gentleman I know of secretary Austin
secretary McDonough secretary Maya
moyakis General milley
and most importantly veterans servicemen
and women and their survivors
today
we once again Gather in this sacred
place
at this solemn hour
to honor
fallen heroes
to once again stand amid the rows of
rows of marble stones and bear Witness
to the brave women and men
who served and sacrifice for our freedom
and for our future
those who died
so our nation might live
every year
as a nation
we undertake this right of remembrance
for we must never forget
the price that was paid
to protect our democracy
we must never forget
the lives these flags flowers
and marble markers represent
a mother
a father
son or daughter
a sister or spouse
a friend
an American
every year we remember
and every year
it never gets easier
to all those here and Across the Nation
who are grieving the loss
of a loved one
who wore the uniform
our goal star families
follow those
with loved ones still missing
unaccounted for
I know
how painful it can be
how it can reopen that rip open that
black hole in the center of your chest
you feel like you're just sinking into
bringing you back to that exact moment
you heard that knock on the door
or the telephone ring
the exact moment
you had to tell your children
and Mom or Dad
would not be coming home
the hurt is still real
still raw
tomorrow marks eight years since we lost
our son Beau
our losses are not the same
he didn't perish in the battlefield
was cancer that stole him
from us a year after being deployed
as a major in the United States Army
National Guard in Iraq
as it is for so many of you
the pain of his loss is with us
every day but particularly Sharp
a Memorial Day
still clear
tomorrow's anniversary
but so is the pride
Jill and I feeling this service
is if I can still hear him saying dad
it's my duty Dad it's my duty
Duty
that was the code
my son lived by
and all those you lost live by
it's the Creed
and millions of service members have
followed
from the fields of Yorktown
to the shores of Normandy
to the rice paddies of Busan
to The Valleys of kind of heart of the
mountains of sinjar and Beyond
many of whom
never returned home
throughout history
these women and men
lay down their lives
not for a place
or a person or president
but for an idea
unlike any other idea in all of human
history
the idea
the idea of the United States of America
this sanctuary
Honors that sacrifice
tells their stories
and in turn it tells our story
the American story
of the patriot who died
to deliver a nation where everyone is
entitled to certain inalienable rights
among them
life
Liberty pursuit of happiness
the story of hundreds of thousands of
soldiers
who shed their blood to make these words
real
story of the Brave Americans who fought
forces of fascism
and died for preservation democracy
as we're reminded by the hundreds of
grades here in section 60 of Arlington
and across our nation
story of the women of man who sacrificed
everything
keep democracy safe and secure during
the last two decades
each of them
each of them a link in a chain of Honor
that stretches back to our founding
fathers in those days
Unbreaking unbending
not just in their Duty and devotion
but something even deeper
and their faith in us
their faith in us
that we will be worthy
of their sacrifice
our service members have always embodied
the highest expectations of our
democracy
they've always held faith in our country
and all that we could be a citadel of
Liberty
a beacon of freedom
for our democracy is our strength
the Wellspring of possibilities
and the source of endless endless
renewal
it's how we've been able to constantly
change and adapt through the centuries
it's why we've always emerged from every
challenge we Face stronger
than we entered it
it's how we come together
as one nation United
and why there's nothing we can't do in
America
when we do it together
the truth
we celebrate this year's remark
we marked 75 years
of a desegregated military 75 years
of women's full integration
50 years
when all volunteer Force
throughout the animals of History
our troops have fought for our democracy
and if necessary died for it
today their service and sacrifice
and that of their families
that goes far beyond
those silent stones out there
we've seen the strength
of our NATO alliance
built from the bonds
that we forever forged in the fires of
two world wars
we see it
the troops Still Standing Sentinel on
the Korean peninsula
preserving peace
side by side with our allies
we see in every base every Barrack every
vessel
around the globe where our military
proudly serves
and stands as a Force for good in the
world
and just as they've kept the ultimate
Faith to our country to our democracy we
must keep the ultimate Faith to them
as a nation
and people have heard me say this for a
long time as a nation
we have many obligations
but I believe it might be fiber on my
being we have only one truly sacred
obligation
to prepare those we send into Harm's Way
and care for them and their families
when they come home
and when they don't
it's a sacred obligation
not based on part of your politics
but on a promise
a promise to unite all of us
there's nothing more important
nothing more sacred
nothing more American
and together
over the last two and a half years we've
worked to make good on that promise
passing more than 25 bipartisan laws to
support
our service members
their families caregivers and survivors
that includes the pack that
most significant law in our nation's
history tell millions of veterans
were exposed to toxic substances and
burn pits
during their military service
pitch the size of football fields
that incinerated the waste of War
such as tires chemicals jet fuel and so
much more
to many of our nation's Warriors that
have selflessly served
only to return home and suffer
from the permanent effects of this
poisonous smoke
too many have died
excuse the personal reference like my
son Beau
they're like Sergeant First Class Heath
Robinson
For Whom the ACT is named
last year
after I
signed The Pact Act
I handed the pen to his daughter
real
she and her grandmother are with us
today
after I handed her the pen
this beautiful little girl is sitting
over there
thank you for Raymond baby
[Applause]
thank you
we've lost half of her world her whole
world
held a pen in her hand
and looked at me and said
thank you
for my daddy
for my dad
God love you honey
but I don't think she was just thanking
me
she's thanking all of us
everyone who fought so hard who came
together to keep our promise to our
veterans
keep the faith
of Our Heroes
on this day
we come together again
to reflect
to remember
but above all to recommit
to the Future
our fallen heroes fought for
that generation of service members who
died
for a future grounded in Freedom
democracy
equality tolerance opportunity and yes
Justice
you use those words all the time
we've seen
of late here and around the world that
they have to continually be fought for
not just for some
but for all
this is more important than just our
system of government
it's the very soul of America
a soul that was forged
by our nation's first Patriots a soul of
the triumph over trials and testing less
than a centuries later
so that endured because of the sacrifice
of generations and generations
of the service members ever since
together
we're not just the fortunate inheritors
of their legacy
we must be the keeper
of their mission the Bears of the flame
of freedom
that kept burning bright for nearly 247
years
that
that's the tourist Memorial to their
lives
our actions every day to ensure that our
democracy endures our constitution
endures and the soul of our nation our
decency endures
ladies and gentlemen
155 years ago our ancestors stood here
and asked themselves what brought our
heroes to this Hallowed Ground
what high motive
LED these brave souls as general
Garfield said to welcome death
today
let's ask ourselves
what can we do what must we do
to pull the vision for which they lived
in which they died
today it's on all of us all of us
to ensure that sacrifice was not in vain
to keep working toward a more perfect
union
one were all women and all men
are created equal
we're the only nation in the world built
on an idea
Every Other Nation
is formed based on things like geography
ethnicity religion
we're the only nation in the world
an idea
that we are all created equal
we haven't always lived up to it
well we've never walked away from it
and today
standing together to honor those
Americans who dared all and gave all for
our nation
we can say clearly we never will
God bless you again all those who gave
their lives so our nation might live
God bless their families
and may God protect our troops today
and always thank you
[Applause]
distinguished guests please stand for
the playing of TAPS and the benediction
[Music]
ah
foreign
[Music]
ah
please receive this closing prayer
God those were such solemn tones that
mean so much to us as a nation
we pray that you grant us the grace to
never forget
and to lead lives worthy of the price
paid on our behalf by those who have
gone on before and those who continue to
serve
God with all humility I thank you for
your goodness to this nation
to our service members and their
families
as our president has stated God we have
a soul
and I pray that you would help us
to align our faith correctly and God
preserve the soul of this nation
preserve the souls of those that serve
with great expectation I ask you to
protect them now wherever they may be
for some are In Harm's Way this day and
many are separated from the ones they
love
bless our government
its leaders
and provide Godly counsel and wisdom to
guide us in your will
God please do Bless America
this nation that we love so much
it's in your holy name I pray amen
please remain standing for the singing
of God Bless America performed by the
United States Navy Band and sea
chanter's chorus
[Music]
God Bless America
[Applause]
[Music]
from the mountains
foreign
[Music]
distinguished guests please remain in
place